i'm angel your heart i'm brett bear i'm
katie pavlich and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday august 4th 2021 i'm jessica
frozenthal
if the pressure doesn't wear you down
maybe some more mandates and rules will
as government and business insist that
you be vaccinated against coven you know
new york starts it now with a
vaccination app
and many other cities i think will
follow i'm dave anthony
the surge at the border keeps growing
even more migrants came to the u.s
last month at levels we haven't seen in
over 20 years
we are in the middle of you know what
seems to be the climax of the surge
right now and
the climax just keeps happening every
month you know the numbers just keep
going higher and higher and higher we
keep thinking well when is this finally
going to slow down
it's not slowing down and i'm janis dean
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
different places are handling a rise in
covet cases and available vaccines
differently places like los angeles
county are implementing indoor
mask mandates again new york city's the
first to essentially implement a vaccine
passport mandate
requiring people to show proof of at
least one covet shot
according to mayor bill de blasio the
key to nyc pass will be a first
in the nation approach it will require
vaccination for workers and customers
in indoor dining in indoor fitness
facilities
indoor entertainment facilities this is
going to be a requirement now places in
florida where many of the new cases and
hospitalizations are occurring aren't
allowed
to implement new mass mandates or
vaccine passport requirements according
to governor ron desantis
we're not shutting down we're going to
have schools open we're protecting
every floridian's job in this state
we're protecting people's small
businesses
these interventions have failed time and
time again
throughout this pandemic not just in the
united states but abroad
they have not stopped the spread white
house officials say they support
local governments and business moves to
require vaccines or masks
president biden encouraged people who
are unvaccinated to get the shock
tuesday
while criticizing states that ban mask
or vaccine mandates
the most extreme of those measures is
like the one in texas that say state
universities or community colleges
could be fined if it allows a teacher to
ask her
unvaccinated students to wear a mask
what are we doing but he warned as long
as the virus continues to
rage outside the u.s potentially more
dangerous variants could arrive at our
shores again
saying it's crucial to continue
providing vaccines to other countries
still the cdc says vaccine rates are
increasing here in the u.s
particularly in states which have so far
had lower numbers of people getting the
vaccine
i was talking to my doctors here at fox
every day about it bill hemmer is
co-host of america's newsroom on fox
and since i had been coming into
the fox headquarters in new york every
day since it started
i i didn't not feel invincible jessica
but i
i felt as if wow heck if i'm gonna get
it i would have had it by now
and i did not have the antibodies and i
i
i don't get a flu shot and i i was
talking with dr mark siegel who's
written books about this stuff for 15
years
and he seemed to be the one person i
knew the best
um about pandemics and trusted the most
because we put him on tv every day
and he said bill this is the safest
vaccine
humankind has ever made and
he said it's not new we've been working
on it for 30 years
it's just now new to this and he said
you're going to be fine
and that that's what that's what led me
to come around i would say in march of
last year and then i got vaccinated in
april
and that that's what led me the other
thing jess i was thinking if i want to
leave the country for anything whether
it's pleasure or for work
i knew i'd have to show proof of a
vaccination
and that has that has been the case
already yeah
are you surprised that vaccine mandates
are proliferating the way they are after
especially after the kind of year we had
right with the anger and resistance over
masks and lockdowns to now know that
businesses and government agencies are
saying you need to be vaccinated or else
it's not just the airlines right did you
see it sounds like you did see that
i could sense it a few weeks ago for
sure and i don't know where it stops by
the way
because if you're following the news you
know every day it brings more headlines
about
more demands upon those that you know
the
the officials who want you as an
american citizen to get the shot
and my guess is after what new york is
announcing that that will continue to um
expand across the country you know new
york starts it now with the vaccination
app
and many other cities i think will
follow i think jessica the reason why
they're doing that
uh we can argue whether it's right wrong
good or bad but
i think in france they started this
about a month ago
same in italy as well and the french
government is reporting that
millions of people in france signed up
for the vaccination once they required
them to do this so there's a little bit
of a
a push and pull on behalf of the public
officials to get
more people vaccinated let's shift
because there's so much other news right
inflation there's this raging debate
right now is it transitory is it not
transitory being you know post pandemic
related and we just need some time to
get through this
either way there are some economic minds
out there who are worried this is not
transitory
and others who say even if this is this
situation could
provide sort of like a price reset at a
higher level
that could be with us for years to come
years to come inflation
inflation seems so nebulous right until
it shows up in your grocery bill
so what what are you what is your sense
as you cover this yeah jessica i'm a
little older than you so i remember the
1970s then i remember the 1980s and
inflation
is no bueno for america it's no good for
the economy
and it's a difficult thing to get out of
once it starts going in that direction i
think that
i think we're headed higher i don't know
how much higher
i listen to voices on the right i listen
to them on the left and a lot of them
think
well some of them think it's benign
others think you know look out for this
because it
won't be just in 2021 when you'll feel
it but you feel it well into 2022.
my fear however is that if congress
is considering four and a half trillion
dollars
in additional spending that the
inflation
fears and feeling we're having right now
will only increase and i think that is
something in all likelihood
you can take to the bank let's not let's
talk about um
you live in new york let's talk about
governor andrew cuomo
um new report found that he
uh did sexually harass several women
current and former state employees this
is a civil
report though one of the investigators
said
now that these facts are are contained
in this report it is up to local police
and prosecutors to do what they will
obviously within statute of limitations
of course
governor cuomo has since responded
saying that the
facts are different than what is in this
report
and that he never touched anyone
inappropriately
there's an impeachment investigation
going on at the assembly level in
in new york state government and um
several lawmakers republicans and
democrats have called for him to resign
what what's going to happen here i think
he's got two options he either steps
down or he fights it and
we'll find out very soon what he decides
to do
there's a third option the speaker of
the assembly the speaker of the house
can conduct impeachment proceedings i i
don't know which of those three
will take place here however i remember
with great clarity
the accusations that were leveled
against president bill clinton in the
1990s
uh from monica lewinsky and
when bill clinton appeared and i believe
it was the
i believe it was the roosevelt room of
the white house there's a painting
behind him in that video that you can
see that will tell you
if i'm right or wrong maybe it was the
yellow room i i can't remember exactly
and he came out and he said i did not
have sexual relations with that woman ms
lewinsky
and off we went uh into um a deep rabbit
hole that eventually led to impeachment
in the house and an acquittal in the u.s
senate
and um that story was with us
for several years and i don't know
if anyone knew what bill clinton would
say
or do at that moment when he approached
the microphone
and i think at least at the moment in
this current holding pattern we find
ourselves jessica
i think the question is open for debate
too as to what governor cuomo does next
let's do some foreign policy here just
for a minute let's talk about china
as we leave afghanistan the chinese are
meeting with the taliban
the chinese are investing heavily in
latin america before his trip to
southeast asia last week our defense
secretary said he was most focused on
activity in the south china sea
china is dominating the headlines what
are you paying attention to as an anchor
reporter when it comes to china
i think what's happening in hong kong is
just reprehensible
and i think as a democratic institution
the united states government needs to do
more and say more
um doing something is difficult yeah um
but saying something and making sure
that you have a voice
uh in the decisions they're making for
jimmy lie and the apple publishing
company
these are big moves you know president g
i think is very interesting maybe your
audience knows this maybe they don't
but what i learned about president xi is
that his father was in the communist
party
and something happened during the 1960s
and he was climbing and he was climbing
within the party
and he got knocked down he made a
mistake or something happened
and he spent the rest of his life trying
to work his way back into the good
graces
of the party and she watched that and
that is very fresh in his mind
and i think when he went out made his
speech three weeks ago and is dressed in
the same uniform as mao
standing above his portrait in a
forbidden city i think that was quite a
statement about how he felt
about the strength and the future for
the communist party in china
one other point jessica in about five
days
in tokyo japan they're going to conclude
the summer games in tokyo
and they're going to have a handoff
ceremony to representatives from beijing
china
and they're going to pass the torch and
they're going to be in masks
and the pandemic will still be raging in
certain parts of the world it will be
under control in certain parts of the
world
but in six months beijing expects to
open the winter games
in china and how will the world body
respond when that happens
will they still be wearing masks in
china then knowing that the communist
party
locked us out entirely from getting any
information or any sense of a
righteous investigation in wuhan that
hasn't happened they're not going to let
us do that
but yet will the world still coalesce
around china in beijing come february of
2022.
my expectation is yes and
let's let's see how this debate plays
out over the next half year wow
um my only other question for you is i
looked up the other day and i saw a
young clint eastwood on my screen and it
was an ad for a fox nation special on
the uh
on the actor director and you're hosting
it what
what did you learn about clint eastwood
that might surprise you
i've seen a ton of his films i i think
one of my favorite actually is in recent
times that he directed an acton called
gran torino i thought it was an
excellent play on like
the sociology of american american
neighborhoods i think it was filmed
outside of detroit michigan real good
film
clint eastwood is 91 now and what i
didn't know about him and our producers
have
done a terrific job of pulling together
all this all these old clips about his
life and
his acting career his directing career
did you know jessica
his films have grossed more than five
billion dollars he's had a career that's
extended more than 60 years
he's been in everything with everyone
and has been
amazing with his staying power but when
he started
he had a way of acting that he did not
want to interrupt and some of these
directors came to him and they talked to
him about being this is a quote now
a hayseed thin rural and very laconic
that he spoke too slowly and had an
overpronounced adam's apple
but eastwood never broke character he
was like well just take the camera
tighter because i'm not going to raise
my voice i'm going to stay in this
character and
you got some of the great lines of all
time and then
later when he went on to direct a lot of
films and this is a line from the the
documentary on fox nation
it said he efficiently made films with
small budgets that almost
always make money he doesn't shoot very
many takes
he doesn't drift from the script and he
always wraps production on time
that tells me he's an efficient
businessman
and then the social commentary that he
weaved into the films later
not just dirty harry four decades ago
but the films that he directed and
starred in later in life really
a social commentary for how he feels
about america
and certain issues check it out we will
phil hemmer thank you so much for your
time you bet
great questions jessica
[Music]
this is janis dean with your fox news
commentary coming up
more immigrants are coming to america
illegally
in the biggest surge in more than 20
years the ap
reports another 210 000 were apprehended
at the border last month
that's more than 10 percent more than
june when vice president harris said
we're not exactly where we want to be
yet but we have seen extreme progress
over these last few months
she has urged people not to come here
while trying to address the root causes
of this migration
in their home countries now of those
immigrants taken into custody in july
more than nineteen thousand were
children traveling alone
an all-time high there is no end in
sight right now that is art del cueto
he is vice president of the national
border patrol council a union of border
agents
i don't care if you're on the right side
or the left side of the aisle we all
deserve to be
safe in our homes there should be no
difference when it comes to our nation's
borders and right now
it's beyond chaotic it's horrific many
of the migrants
are crossing over in texas the epicenter
is here in the rio grande valley where
we are
and border agents out here are just
completely overwhelmed
bill malugen is a fox news national
correspondent covering the situation at
the border
in la jolla over the weekend they
apprehended more than eight thousand
people
more than three thousand in one 24-hour
period and as of this weekend dhs
sources were telling us border patrol
stations here in the mcallen area were
nearly 600 percent over capacity so
it's not slowing down at all it's only
getting worse and these numbers are
shooting up like a rocket
yeah that's a that's a big number but
these are just the ones
that border patrol stops or does border
patrol get most of them what what
happens when these migrants
do get into texas when they finally
cross over
so so that's a good point that yes these
apprehension numbers these are only the
ones that we know about we'll never know
about the godaways and it's impossible
to count all of those because we don't
know how many slip through the border
when border agents aren't able to get to
them and what's happening is the cartels
and the smugglers are very smart what
they do is they send over
large huge family unit groups across the
border
and they know that border patrol
resources are going to get sucked up
having to process those family units it
takes hours sometimes and what they'll
do is when those family units are being
processed
elsewhere along the border they will
send the runners the criminals the
cartel guys
the drug runners the people who do not
want to be caught and we've we've caught
that actually happening on our drone
before
so there's just no way of knowing how
many runners actually get through
because border agents are also telling
us that their manpower is running really
low right now they've got so many agents
who have been pulled off the line having
to do
processing paperwork social worker sorts
of things that they have fewer and fewer
agents actually out patrolling the front
lines
and that's leaving sections of the
border open and exposed
when people who are americans think of
apprehension or
being stopped or being arrested there's
a lot of fear in that
but when the immigrants come into texas
in the la jolla area is that what you
see
are they're not fearful are they i mean
some of these people are happy that
they've been stopped correct
yeah so a lot of them the family units
of migrants that we see out here they
are
they are wanting to be apprehended by
border patrol they'll come up to us and
say donde esta la migra where's border
patrol
actively seeking out agents because they
know their family units if they claim
asylum or they claim
fear they've got a good chance of
staying they'll basically be processed
and taken down to downtown mcallen
likely released to the catholic charity
where they'll be given a bus ticket or a
plane ticket to go wherever they want
with a court date in the future
so that's why a lot of these folks are
you'll see in our videos sometimes
they're smiling or giving us thumbs up
or dancing they are looking to be
apprehended
at least those family units the opposite
side of the coin are the runners
who do not want to be caught because
sometimes they are criminals
smugglers that sort of thing or they're
they've been deported before and
they don't want to be deported again now
you mentioned the catholic charity
there has been a story about a couple of
hotels
where they have put some of these
migrants who have been testing positive
for covid now when do these migrants get
tested does border patrol do that they
don't do it at the initial point of
contact so when border patrol encounters
the migrants out in the field
they are not tested there when they're
tested is when they're potentially
handed off to hhs
or when they're handed off to the
catholic charities before they go into
the charities custody they will
sometimes be tested
at a site in downtown mcallen through a
third party
now yes those those stories about the
hotels are true what happened is these
migrants were coveted positive
border patrol released them to the
custody of that catholic charity
and then the catholic charity quietly
started placing them in hotels
here in the mcallen area and there are
two that we know of so far one in la
jolla one in weslico
the one in la jolla blew up because some
of those infected migrants
left the room and went into a
whataburger and had no mass on and were
coughing all over the place and some of
the patrons complained
police did an investigation and later
found out that the charity had put him
in there
and charity has not told any of these
cities that they're putting these
migrants in there so i actually
reached out to the executive director of
the charity and i asked her how many
coveted positive migrants have you guys
placed in hotels here in the rio grande
valley and she told me that she has been
advised not to comment
advised by who exactly that's the
question
when some of these migrants are put on
buses
obviously it's crowded on the bus have
they been tested before that
nope they're being placed on the bus
having absolutely no idea how much covet
is on the bus they're all given little
surgical mass and then they're crammed
together
and that's why there's been outbreaks
that's why agents are getting sick
migrants are getting sick the first two
weeks of july migrant cases
here in the rio grande valley surged
over 900 percent the numbers are just
shooting up like a rocket as the delta
variant is spreading texas has a
republican-led government
trying to deal with the surge on its own
americans all over this country ought to
be damn
angry what's happening to their country
total invasion
and people in every state are going to
die
through a combination of people coming
in illegally
with covid with the fentanyl drugs or
setting an all-time record
lieutenant governor dan patrick now
texas is working to restart border wall
construction
and governor greg abbott has ordered
state troopers to arrest
immigrants for trespassing so that just
got underway
at last check it started when i was in
del rio two weeks ago
and i think they've only at last check
had like a dozen or so migrants arrested
on trespassing charges
and they get taken to a jail i believe
it's called dilly texas it's kind of
like an hour north of um
del rio but yes there what they're doing
is abbot
is uh he's putting up this chain-link
fence near the rio grande with barbed
wire on the top and no trespassing signs
so
the idea is if anybody climbs that fence
crosses it that sort of a thing
they are they can be arrested on state
crimes
rather than federal crime so instead of
calling border patrol and saying hey
we've got some migrants here you guys
need to pick them up
texas state troopers can just arrest
them themselves and charge them under
texas laws and put them in texas jails
and that that process is just getting
started president biden has said he's
undoing damage his predecessor did
implementing a more humane border policy
but something from the trump era remains
in place
title 42 a cdc order aimed at protecting
public health
it was extended monday to prevent
covid's spread
title 42 allows customs and border
officials to expel immigrants who come
here illegally not let them in
back to bill malugen is that happening
in some cases yes but it's typically
only happening immediately with
single adult males uh from the northern
triangle countries guatemala honduras
and el salvador
if there are families coming across and
they are claiming fear or asylum they
are not being title 42
they are being allowed to stay okay so
the crowds that we
see those are families coming here
almost all of them yes are massive
massive family units yes
there was drone video you you have been
showing on on the channel
of a big big crowd of of migrants
where was that that is in mission texas
under ansel dewis bridge
ansel dewis bridge is about a mile away
from a very popular
crossing spot at the rio grande so the
migrants just illegally cross they walk
into the u.s and
there's actually a bunch of trails with
signs pointing them where to go
and they pop out right into that area
and when the surge is really bad
it is absolutely packed under there but
what that video that you're talking
about it is the worst we have
ever ever seen it maybe before there's a
hundred or so people
there's well over a thousand there and
it's it just goes to show we are in the
middle
of you know what seems to be the climax
of the surge right now
and the climax just keeps happening
every month you know the numbers just
keep going higher and higher and higher
we keep thinking well when is this
finally going to slow down
it's not slowing down and it hasn't now
you mentioned asylum
these migrants know that they have to
say that they are fearing
for their lives or their families in the
country where they're from
in order to at least get a an asylum
hearing
the hearings themselves what's the
process for that
so it kind of depends although all of
that is very backlogged right now so
what will happen is say a family unit
comes across
and they say they they fear for their
lives in you know whatever country
they're coming from
they will be given what's known as an
nta a notice to appear
and a court date in who knows six months
a year two years maybe three years
depending on how backlogged it is and
they will be released into the country
and they'll they'll fly and get bust
whenever they want
um and then they will they will either
show up for that hearing in the future
or they won't a lot of them don't show
up and in some cases
axios just had a report a few days ago
that like about 50 000 migrants have
been released into the country
with no with no court date and
absolutely no way of tracking them they
were just flat out released and there's
no way of knowing where they went
and only 13 of them ever show up to the
local ice offices to register
okay now under president trump they
would have had to wait in mexico correct
correct and that's been one of i talked
to a lot of these migrants when they
come across
and they tell us that was one of the
biggest deterrents was the remain in
mexico policy before they didn't want to
have to wait in mexico while their case
was being heard now that they can come
into the united states
and move around here while their case is
being heard that's a lot more enticing
for them
the surge kind of times up with right
when president biden took over in
february is when you started seeing
those numbers just shooting up and based
off the migrants we've talked to
remain in mexico was a big part of the
reason why have you been able to talk to
any border patrol agents say off the
record
or who didn't want to be quoted but but
we're telling you anything
yeah i mean they we talk to them all the
time and not obviously not on the record
but
the morale has never been lower they've
never been more frustrated they feel
like they've been turned into
social workers they're not actually
being able to do their
law enforcement job and physically
patrol
the line of the border they're basically
being turned into administrative guys
doing paperwork all day because these
family units don't stop coming across
because they know
now is the time for them to claim asylum
because they will have a higher chance
of being able to stay in the united
states under president biden
than they would under president trump
now the body administration said it's
you know it's seasonal
a lot of this surge this year yeah
that's that that's just not true and
it's blatantly not true
and a lot of the statements the
administration has made throughout this
crisis whether it's maiork is saying the
border is closed kamala here is saying
that there is extreme progress being
made
or president biden saying in a cnn town
hall that there's been a 90
reduction in the amount of migrants in
border patrol custody
the first two statements are just
completely false and biden's statement
yeah
if if if there's a big decrease in the
amount of people in border patrol
custody it's because they're all being
let go
and we got video of it yesterday i mean
we were in downtown mcallen as border
patrol was just dropping off busload
after busload after busload of migrants
at the catholic charity they were then
walked over to the bus station and they
were out of town and they're just moving
elsewhere into the united states bill
malugen fox news national correspondent
who's been our
eyes and ears right in the border for
the last uh several months and now in la
jolla texas bill
good to have you with us thanks for
joining us thanks for having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind i've always said it
doesn't matter what ultimately brings
governor andrew cuomo down
and if it's tuesday's sexual misconduct
accusations that lead to his exit from
politics
then that's okay with me i've gotten to
know a few of the women that have
accused the governor of misconduct
and we all want the same thing for cuomo
to finally leave office
tuesday's damning report from the
attorney general leticia james concluded
that the governor
the same one who was being hailed as a
presidential candidate last summer
sexually harassed multiple women and in
doing so
violated federal and new york state law
listening to these women's stories of
being terrified demeaned and being taken
advantage of
made me so angry and not just because of
the situations they were forced into
but because cuomo almost got away with
it
this is just one of the many
investigations into the governor's
conduct and behavior
cuomo's power hungry reign over new york
extended into a pandemic
with the governor celebrating himself
instead of actually helping the people
he represents
sending covet positive patients into
nursing homes for 46 days
helped kill thousands of elderly
including my husband's parents
but if you watched the news last spring
you probably
would never have known he was riding
high on his popularity by winning an
emmy award
creating and selling creepy posters of a
conquered covid mountain
and pitching a 5.1 million dollar book
all the while he covered up how his
decisions led to seniors dying
by the thousands there were also friends
and family coveted tests for his brother
cnn anchor chris cuomo and others while
nursing homes weren't allowed to use
them
he even used taxpayer resources to drive
them
to and from the lab in upstate new york
cuomo has always played the victim from
the very beginning and blamed everyone
else for his no-good terrible
deadly mistakes tuesday was no exception
after attorney general james issued her
scathing report he had a taped response
saying he's always been this way
just ask his friends and family he even
played a photo montage of him kissing
all sorts of people
young old and many many politicians
in fact his 83-page response included
eight
pages of him hugging politicians
this proves nothing except that cuomo is
grasping at anything to take the blame
off him
and his behavior i think we're all sick
and tired of this governor making
excuses and blaming the victims
i would challenge the governor to try to
make it all about him in front of
grieving families someday
it's now time for other leaders on both
sides of the aisle to demand
his resignation but one thing i've
learned the past year and a half
covering albany lawmakers is how
spineless they are when it comes to
holding the executive chamber
accountable
they've had enough time to impeach him
for months now but have been
stonewalling
and waiting for someone else to do it
for them perhaps
if it's not the attorney general telling
them he's broken the law
who will now is the time to do the right
thing
because lord knows the governor won't
janis dean fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at fox news
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news
go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and
opinion you trust and click the fox news
rundown playlist for the latest episodes